momento de hablar de economía en directo
América pero yo le doy la bienvenida a
mi compañero Juan Pablo locumé ahora soy
Juan Pablo le había cambiado el nombre
anteriormente pero empezamos con
noticias del petróleo porque hoy se
conoció una noticia importante que
seguramente va a afectar la economía
mundial esta vez el sector petrolero Así
es Andrés pues la ope más que es la
alianza de países exportadores de
petróleo decidió reducir drásticamente
la producción de crudo a solamente dos
millones de barriles por día a partir de
noviembre una decisión que se traduce al
mayor recorte desde 2020 y que
evidentemente afectará la economía
mundial como usted lo decía desde ayer
los mercados ya anticipaban un posible
recorte por parte del grupo liderado por
Arabia Saudita y Rusia y el Brand Cerro
ayer martes con una importante ganancia
de más del 3%. hoy el petróleo de
referencia de Estados Unidos El wti ganó
un 0,35% llegando hasta los 88 dólares y
El crudo brent de Reino Unido creció
hasta los 93 dólares con un del
1,78%. el petróleo cotiza muy por debajo
de sus máximos de verano debido a los
temores de que las principales economías
mundiales como Estados Unidos o Europa
se hundan en una recesión debido a la
alta inflación algo a lo que se suma
además a la crisis energética en el
viejo continente debido a los recortes
de Rusia en represalias por la guerra en
Ucrania escuchamos
probaremos continuamente que la OPEP más
está aquí no sólo para quedarse sino
para quedarse como una fuerza moderadora
para lograr la estabilidad y la mejora
de la anomalía de apoyo a la economía
mundial Juan Pablo se conoció la
inflación anual de Colombia en Qué
porcentaje se ubicó la tasa pues Andrés
es el porcentaje más alto en 23 años no
se registraba esa exactamente desde 1999
según el departamento de estadística de
ese país el costo de vida para los
colombianos aumentó un
0,93%, Comparado con el mismo periodo
del año anterior
con esto la inflación interanual se
ubicó en
11,44% en septiembre comparada con el
mismo periodo del año pasado cuando fue
del
4,5%. los productos que más aumentaron a
usted que pues nosotros que vimos acá en
Colombia para que lo tengan en cuenta
fueron los electrodomésticos como
neveras y lavadoras y lo segundo que más
encareció fueron los alimentos y bebidas
alcohólicas como es de esperarse con una
inflación elevada los bancos centrales
de la mayoría de países incrementan las
tasas de interés para mermar la
capacidad de endeudamiento y el poder
adquisitivo de las personas el banco de
la República de Colombia hizo
Exactamente eso luego de conocer el
elevado 11,4% de la inflación y el
presidente Gustavo Petro criticó la
medida asegurando que el aumento de los
tipos de interés lo que hará será traer
la recesión mundial a la economía de
Colombia Juan Pablo la Organización
Mundial del Comercio pronostica un
crecimiento menor para 2023 como es eso
Andrés Pues según el organismo con sede
en Ginebra la cantidad de bienes
enviados entre países este año puede que
aumente un
3,5%, algo mucho mayor de lo que se
anticipó que era solamente de un 3%,
ahora para el año que viene la
organización Espera que el comercio
tenga un crecimiento de tan solo el
3,4%. un punto porcentual menos que lo
que se logrará al finalizar este 2022 si
hablamos de lo ocurrido este año la omc
asegura que el aumento fue gracias al
alto volumen del comercio mediado pues
este año especialmente por la
comercialización de países productores
de petróleo y gas en medio en medio
oriente luego de que el continente
europeo buscara alternativas tras los
recortes de Rusia Esto fue lo que dijo
la directora general de la organización
hoy la economía mundial se enfrenta una
crisis de múltiples frentes el
endurecimiento monetario está
convirtiéndose en una carga para el
crecimiento en gran parte del mundo
incluido Estados Unidos en Europa Los
Altos precios de la energía están
agobiando a los hogares Y las empresas y
en China los brotes de Kobe 19 continúan
para interrumpir la producción y la vida
económica ordinaria los países en
desarrollo de bajos ingresos en
particular enfrentan serios riesgos de
inseguridad alimentaria y
sobreendeudamiento Juan Pablo y nuestra
cifra del día Andrés 70 millones de
dólares Esa es la multa que está
solicitando el consejo regulador de
publicidad en Ginebra en contra de la
compañía meta por publicar anuncios no
autorizados las leyes de publicidad en
Nigeria requieren que el regulador
apruebe los anuncios en función de
ciertos criterios según expertos esto
podría perjudicar a las empresas de la
economía más grande de África porque
estas dependen en gran medida de los
anuncios locales para su crecimiento más
problemas para meta Juan Pablo Muchas
gracias por la información económica
seguimos con más aquí en directo América
[Música]